the Joe Rogan experience do you have the
same optimistic perception about the
ocean well first of all let me say what
I think about the word optimism because
I know that you're not doing this but a
lot of people when they talk to me and
call me an optimist
they actually means a lot an over
optimist and will they call themselves a
realist they mean that they're a
pessimist so but but anyway about the
ocean of course I mean what's the
difference you know there's certainly
there's a lot to do one big problem
right now of course is the ocean is
storing a lot of carbon and releasing a
lot as its warming up so we definitely
have to fix that as well but it's part
of the same problem you know the less
carbon there in the atmosphere the less
the less of a problem that is direct
carbon removal from the atmosphere in a
technology that absolutely you know
burgeoning now and direct carbon capture
from the ocean seems to be something
that the equally plausible that
obviously different I'm I'm optimistic
in terms of the ability to clean up the
ocean I've had boy onslaught on a couple
times aware of him doing his devices
that he's created to remove plastics and
other garbage from the ocean
my concern is wild fish that the
depletion of the fish populations is an
unprecedented rate and it seems to be
we're somewhere in the neighborhood of
50 years away from a catastrophic
complete collapse of wild fisheries well
right course this is again a problem
that can be fixed by technology you know
if you can make artificial red meat why
not make artificial fish well that
wouldn't sir that would be good that we
can have artificial fish but that
wouldn't necessarily make that
population rebound we would have to make
large steps to try to bring back the the
equilibrium of the ocean that's not
clear I mean it's not clear no I mean
most of as I understand anyway this is
not an area I'm expert on of course so I
may be wrong but most of the severe
depletions of populations of specific
fish fish species are because of fishing
fishing so if we're not doing the
overfishing so we're making the
if I'm fish elf we're on land mm-hmm
well I'm sure a lot of it is being done
by the United States but I'm sure and
Great Britain and a lot of first world
countries but I'm sure a lot of it is
also being done by countries that can't
afford to make this artificial fish or
don't have the access to it or at least
in the time period that it's going to
take before these fisheries rebound it's
when I talk to people that have an
understanding of wildlife in the ocean
they say it's a desperate time and it's
a desperate time that is not really
being recognized by the general
population because they can still get
sushi they could still get a little bit
at the local market but that if you talk
to the fishermen if you talk to the
wildlife biologists that are really
studying the levels they're like this is
nearing a point of no return yeah III
wouldn't dispute that I think it's
urgent but all that really says is we
should be investing more in the
development of these new technologies
that will hasten the and if they even
bother with wild fish if they mean if
they can make artificial meat I wonder
if the people really get into artificial
fish as well doctor well no I guess so
but some of them are not gonna make the
cut like no one's getting artificial
toll Opia why not it's not that good not
yet so they've looked at it sure why
don't even call it tilapia then but like
to cook people like the night like yes
I'm really optimistic about artificial
meat I mean it seems that they're I mean
at one point I was like a quarter
million dollars for a hamburger and now
they've got it down to a point where you
could actually make an animal meat
product that does not come from an
animal dying that's right they're very
close to be able to make this in a mass
marketed way okay that's interesting I'm
excited about that I think that's very
interesting
[Applause]